good evening this is zero five seven  with a public service announcement here  in the United States and abroad SCPs are  starving and homeless but you can help  by sponsoring an SCP through the  Christian SCP fund for less than a  dollar a day  your contribution can provide scp-053  with the clothes she needs to go to  school you can keep scp-682 s  containment tank full of hydrofluoric  acid you can even feed a puffer kitten  for an entire month  when you sponsor an SCP will send you  its picture and containment report you  may write your SCP whenever you wish and  quarterly progress reports let you see  how your sponsorship is helping  please give think of the puffer kittens  disclaimer the Christian SCP fund is not  responsible for injury sustained while  visiting euclid nikita level s EPS and  met effects of letters from the recipe  mental disturbances caused by picture of  your SCP eg a